[Music]
now today for our daily cancellation
let's look at two stories that are
happening at the same time first
morgan wallen is watching his career
implode before his eyes as a consequence
of a video that catches the country star
country music star uh using a a racial
slur
now wallen and his buddies were laughing
and carrying on after returning home
from a night of drinking this past
weekend and their antics were so loud
and disruptive that they woke up the
neighbors
one of whom decided to pull out a phone
and document
the commotion unfortunately for wallen
the camera had been turned on right
before
he shouted to one of his friends across
the street presumably referring to
another friend who was in perhaps
an especially drunken state he said take
care of this
blank n-word here's uh here's the video
hey hey actually hey y'all you're up
take care of this
hey gracie take care
[Music]
okay so i just i wanted you to
to see or hear that just to get the tone
of it
um it's clear that wallen used a word he
should not have used it's also clear
that he didn't mean for it to be public
though he did shout it in the street
which is not a good way of keeping
things private
and he meant it as a joke okay
nonetheless as expected the penalties
have been quite significant wallet
apologized profusely but that didn't
stop the inevitable from happening his
record label suspended him the academy
of country music awards
revoked his eligibility cumulus media
iheart media and siriusxm
pulled all of his songs from their
stations effectively removing him from
the radio altogether
okay this is the swiftest and harshest
backlash we have probably seen against a
star
a star musician in i don't know how long
years
at least even though star musicians do
and say objectionable things all the
time
while wallenstar is rapidly plummeting
after saying one offensive thing a thing
which if context matters was said
drunkenly and in jest
another star is ascending again after a
minor and temporary dip
the juxtaposition here i think is quite
instructive nick cannon
and viacom cbs have reunited and are
feeling so good
and the production of his vh1 series
wild and out will resume following a
brief suspension
of their relationship following comments
that canon made
on his podcast last summer now you might
remember what provoked the backlash was
canon's claim
that black people can't be anti-semitic
because they are
they are the semitic people and they are
quote the true hebrews
this is what prompted the brief severing
of ties with viacom cbs and an apology
from canon
and but that's all water under the
bridge now apparently canon's career is
back and it's on track and he's rolling
again
no problem but the true hebrew stuff
wasn't close to the worst thing he said
during the podcast
the the really offensive and racist
remarks were never acknowledged by the
media or by canon himself or even by
viacom cbs when they initially condemned
his statements
they just ignored this part canada in
fact has faced no consequence
not even a temporary consequence for his
actual racist diatribe in which he
claimed
that white people fear black quote
unquote
and have a quote lack of compassion
because of their melanin deficiency
and if that wasn't enough he also said
that white people are quote a little
less
read inferior to black people and that
because they don't have
the power of the sun they behave quote
out of fear
out of low self-esteem and out of
deficiency
and can quote only act evil robbing and
raping in order to survive he says
white people can and says are quote
closer to animals and are quote the true
savages
okay that's these are all things that he
said um this
is by far in a way the most racist thing
that any celebrity of his stature has
said in many years
if you've got a if you've got a more
racist thing then let me know and he
never apologized for it and he never
now he has his job back so let's stack
these two situations up against each
other wallin
used a racial slur in a non-racial
context
was drunk and joking and never meant for
it to be recorded
canon on the other hand expressed his
true feelings about white people
with thorough detail and did so publicly
and proudly his opinion as he says
himself
is that white people are sub-human
animalistic savages
and are inferior to him so who's
committed the greater sin here
who suffered the worst consequence
objectively there is little
doubt that wallen is the lesser offender
also the lesser human by nick cannon's
way of thinking
and even less doubt that he has endured
the more severe professional
consequences
he's also the only one between the two
of them who apologized
so talking about privilege as we were
earlier who has the real privilege here
the man who said a bad thing apologized
and lost his career anyway
or the man who said a worse thing didn't
apologize
and got his career back you cannot say
that the first man has all the privilege
without removing
all meaning from the word privilege
so is it enough then in that case to say
that white privilege is a myth
but black privilege is real is that what
i'm
getting to here no not quite because if
it were as simple as that
then candace owens not only black but a
woman as well
would enjoy all of nick cannon's
privilege and then some
but that's clearly not the case so
rather than black or white privilege
it's probably more accurate to speak of
identity privilege or more accurately
tribal privilege your privilege is tied
to your tribe
and within the privileged tribe the
pecking order is determined by a
complicated and convoluted hierarchy of
identities
nick cannon can survive and thrive in
spite of his insanely racist views or
even partly because of them maybe
do first and foremost to his leftism
okay now if canon were a conservative an
acolyte of
you know thomas soul instead of louis
farrakhan
there would be no redemption arc for him
but within that leftist tribe which
affords him power and prestige to begin
with
he earns his rank according to his
racial and sexual identity
though the privilege of his tribe so
through the privilege of his tribe
and by its own internal rules he can say
pretty much whatever he wants about race
but he's not at the very top of the
intersectional heap so if
so if instead of white people he had
labeled say
gay people or transgenders or women
as quote a little less then he'd be
banished from polite society
with all the same speed and vigor that
has been directed at morgan wallin
now as for morgan wallen he's white
a country singer and he lives in
nashville which makes him for all
intents and purposes anyway a
conservative or at least conservative
adjacent
he is the wrong race and in the wrong
tribe
the only privilege he has then is the
kind he can buy with all his wealth
and that'll probably be enough to keep
him comfortable for a while but not
enough to save his career or his
reputation
and this is privilege this is how
privilege works
this is nick cannon shows exactly how
privileged works
it's kind of confusing it's a tangled
web indeed
but this is the way it goes and this is
why
the concept of white privilege is
cancelled
and nick cannon is cancelled by me
anyway if not by anybody else
for whatever that's worth which is
unfortunately nothing at all
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat
appreciated